David Feherty joins us from the Open
Championship David thanks for joining us
what kind of history do you have playing
in the Open Championship
oh well that's sort of a checkered one
dad I played in probably a dozen maybe
14 Open Championships the highest that
place was fourth and Turnberry
in 94 and then our six Troon where it
was almost as dry there as it is here in
1989 I played like crap most famous
player you played with famous players
probably Tom Watson yeah that's pretty
good if you play an Open Championship
and you're in the group with Tom Watson
that means you're probably doing
something well how do you explain for
people who will never get a chance to
play in Scotland how would you explain
what this golf is like and how to play
this kind of course well this kind of
course which is one of the artists in
the world when you play it under normal
conditions is it's just one of those
places anywhere in Scotland's just don't
go into the sand unless you can possibly
avoid it
because it's basically a one-shot family
every time you do with this kind of golf
it's it is target golf still but the
target is moving and quite often it's 60
70 yards short of the green and then you
have to read what the ball is going to
do on its way to the green you know so
there's a great deal more to think about
here and this links golf and there is an
hour kind of american-style target cell
and these bunkers are like caves that
you walk into David it's not like our
typical our bunkers here in the United
States no these are mine shots
I used to work for my both read daily
won the Open Championship in 1947 my
plane was amend an Irish Open once where
he was still probably good 65 years old
and he got out of this big deep bunker
by the 6th green to Fort mark and he
said to me I can
play just as well as they ever could
just a bit smaller because but I can't
get out of these bunkers so I said to
mr. Daley he thought about one of those
new sandwiches with a level off they
said no I can get the ball right
I can't we're seeing these guys hit
drives
I think Dustin Johnson had a four
hundred-plus yard drive today how much
does that help you on that golf course
or does it well I've just done a
three-hour cent more of an idea of what
what the problem is no the problem is
you can't hit the fairways at all
you know if you had a four iron off the
tee you're almost as likely to miss the
fairway with that as you are with the
driver so you might as well hit the
driver you're going to miss the fairway
it should be a little closer to the
green how many hotels are around
Carnoustie like where do the players
stay most of the players are saying in
Dundee and quite a few of them of the
locals here in Congress you basically
they all go to America the weekend they
open and they rent the houses to
Americans who all come here the
difference between the Scottish and the
Irish is what well the way we treat our
sheep and you see the Irish invented
both the kilt and the bagpipes and I'm
very serious
the original coat was called a saffron
it was a sort of a mustard colors of the
Irish war and the bagpipes
the original bagpipes have two chapters
and they're called the uilleann pipes
and they've got a much more mournful
Squire they're sort of assigned than the
Scottish pipes that have three chapters
I'll tell you you never know what you're
going to learn on your show can you play
the bagpipes I did I never played the
back side so we thought of them as a
weapon of destruction rather a musical
instrument you've worn it killed though
oh yeah I am scots-irish and you know
the Scottish side of my family are the
Roberts so I wear the Robert start
yeah is there a special occasion when
you bring out the kilt well and the only
time I've worn it was last year our year
before I tell you when I made a very
foolish bet with Justin Rose and Jordan
speith I told him and third round if
they both made the cut I would wear a
kilt the following day because they were
both struggle to make the cut and they
both made a cut
wouldn't there was a large gust of wind
at one point and it rendered several
children in need of therapy for several
months how do you expect this to play
out David you know I'm just watching
Tigers and he looks awfully good the
Soaring has been fantastic today
certainly in the early part of the day I
don't expected to be that good because I
don't think anyone's mentioned it yet
the greens are actually getting sneaky
fast they're starting to get a little
shine on the top under but I see a lot
of short putts missed playing on the
weekend so I knew of grass and it gets a
little sort of a flower on top and when
the ball slows tonic that's all wobbly
oh nightmare all right who did you pick
by the way I to the start of the week I
liked Matt Kuchar I think he knocks on
the door often enough
Alex Noren Tommy Fleetwood and Parker
great those are my four is Tommy
Fleetwood becoming a rock star he kind
of it he's a really nice kid he doesn't
really believe his own his own press
nobody is kind of a cult figure without
hair oh I love the hair I hope you dig
you know and then Lenny dubbed fairway
Jesus I don't know if that's an official
nickname there that will be used on the
broadcast but we loved it well oh yeah
you can get away with it on Golf Channel
there but probably not on NBC over the
weekend hey it's great to talk to you
and have fun over there behave it's a
David Ferrie NBC's
scoff analyst and a host of fantasy on
Golf Channel for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]